We have covered a lot of topics. We have talked
about how the sense of vision evolved. We
have talked about the details of human vision.
We have looked at some of the variety of animal
vision. We have talked about how vision is
a process where the eye is actively steered
around the scene in order to maximise our
understanding of that particular scene.
So now it is appropriate to talk about robots
and vision, and look at how robots have used
the sense of vision in order to be able to
perform tasks, in a similar way to which humans
and animals use vision to perform tasks.
The robot on the left is a very famous robot
called Shakey. Developed at SRI International
in the 1960s. And it has a television camera
on the top, which it uses for navigation.
The robot on the right is one that I built
in the early 2000s, and it has got quite a
number of cameras on board, and they are a
little bit interesting to look at. In the
front is a stereo camera pair and it is a
bit like our own two eyes. It allows the robot
to determine three dimensional structure of
the world in front of it. On the top, it has
a very shiny mirror object and that is part
of what we call a panoramic camera assembly.
There is a camera looking up at that mirror
and that allows the robot to see 360 degrees—it
can see forwards, backwards and side ways.
It’s sometimes called an omni-cam or a panoramic
camera.
The last camera on this robot is a wide-angle
camera on the side. It has a fish eye lens,
so it almost has a hemispherical field of
view. And that can look at what is happening
to the side of the robot.
The current Mars Rover, the Curiosity Rover,
has got a large number of cameras on board
that it uses for a variety of functions.
Now the business of teaching machines to see
is the field of computer vision, and that
is an activity that has been going on since
perhaps the 1960s. Some important early work
was carried out by Larry Roberts at MIT as
part of his PhD project. Larry went on to
do other very important things and was very
instrumental in creating the internet. So
in his thesis work what he was doing was taking
a picture of an object, and this is a very
simple wooden block object, took a picture
with a TV camera and was trying to work out
what shape it was. So he went through a number
of vision processing steps and these are the
sorts of things we will cover in following
lectures.
One of the first steps was to find the edges
of this object and once he had found the edges
of the object he would try to fit line segments
to those edges and once he knew those line
segments, he knew something about the way
images are formed. He could then say something
about the three dimensional shape of this
particular object. So what we have here is
a system that can take an image and process
it and come up with a three dimensional model
of that shape. So it is a very simple form
of object recognition. The computers take
an image and made a discussion about what
sort of object that it was looking at. That’s
sufficient information then for a robot to
make a move, go and pick that object up and
perhaps manipulate it in some way.
So why is vision a good sensor for a robot
to have? There are a few reasons why I believe
vision is an important and very practical
sensor for a robot.
Firstly, the cameras themselves are now very
cheap and the reason for this is because cameras
are built into everything; built into cell
phones, built into laptops, and so on. So
the actual sensor the equivalent of a retina
is now a device that perhaps costs less then
a dollar. Lenses are smaller, cameras are
small and cheap.
The other reason that is really important
is that computation is now really cheap; we
have very powerful computer chips and lots
and lots of memory, and so this enables us
to run algorithms to process the data that
comes out of the sensor chip.
So this combination of very effective, high
resolution, colour, cheap sensors, with abundant
computation are the foundations on which we
can build robot vision systems.
Here is a really interesting graph from Ray
Kurzweil, and he talks a lot about the way
computation power has changed over time, and
this is a logarithmic vertical scale and he’s
plotting a number of data points that represent
a number of calculations per second you can
buy for a thousand dollars over time. And
we can see that this is an exponential plot
on a logarithmic vertical scale. So what it
is showing is computation is really increasing,
increasingly rapidly with time. And this is
fundamentally Ray Kurzweil's thesis.
So if we extrapolate this into the future,
we can see that we are about here, and we
have computational power of effectively one
mouse brain.
By the early 2020s we should have, for a thousand
dollars, the computational power of a human
brain. And by 2050 when many of you will be
alive, perhaps at the ends of your working
careers, for a thousand dollars you will be
able to buy enough computing power to the
equivalent of all human brains on the planet.
That is a pretty amazing prediction and so
clearly very, very exciting times ahead.
So what practical things have roboticists
been doing with sensor vision?
We hear a lot in recent times about self-driving
cars, Google cars and so on, but the actual
history of self-driving cars goes back a long
way. There was some very significant research
program in Europe in the 1980s called Prometheus,
and a lot of very fundamental work was done
by a scientist called Ernst Dickmanns. He
automated this van. It had a number of cameras
in the front looking outwards, and it was
able to drive along autobahns at high speed.
A number of significant landmark achievements
were made by this particular van and some
of it immediate descendants.
Another landmark achievement was from some
researchers from Carnegie Mellon University,
who automated a car primarily using the sensor
vision, and drove it across America. The journey
took a few days, around four thousand kilometres,
and there were relatively few human interventions.
This video shows a humanoid robot catching a ball.
Here we see it again in slow motion.
Now the robot has a pair of cameras in its head,
which allows it to estimate the distance
to the ball; uses that information to model
how a ball moves through space in order to
plan the motion that the arm should take to
intercept the ball. So the robot’s head
has a number of sensors: pair of cameras as
I mentioned, but also some tilt sensors, so
it can work out where the head is pointing
in space. Now you can see the positions of
the ball as seen by its left and right eye
as a function of time, and here you can see
an animation of the robot’s hand moving
to intercept the path of the ball.
Here is a flying robot which we actually looked
at up close in the Out and About with Robots
video, in the Robotics course some of you
might have seen earlier. This robot is equipped
with a stereo pair of cameras again. So again
like our own two eyes, this enables the robot
to sense an obstacle in front of it, by working
out the three dimensional structure of the
world in front using information from two
cameras and a fair amount of processing on
board.
Another robot developed by myself and some
colleagues at CSIRO, and this underwater robot
has also got a stereo pair of cameras. It
has got two cameras that look downwards and
two cameras which look frontwards. The downward
looking cameras are estimating the distance
of the seabed from the robot, and this robot
is trying to maintain a constant altitude
above the sea bed. And it does that using
the three dimensional information from the
downward looking stereo cameras. The frontward
looking stereo cameras are used to detect obstacles.
Here we see what the world looks like through
the eyes of a mobile robot. This particular
robot has got a stereo camera pair which allows
it to create a three dimensional model of
the world through which it is moving. And
that is really useful in order to determine
what is a flat surface that it could drive
over, and what is a wall, or human being,
or some other kind of obstacle.
Here we have something a bit different. Here
we have a single camera looking downwards
at a coral reef, and the camera is being carried
by a robot. Now we are able to use a number
of mathematical techniques to combine the
information from these multiple camera videos
to create a three dimensional model of the
coral reef. We do this from a number of single
camera views. Now we smooth that three dimensional
mesh; we drape the original imagery over it
to create a texture map surface. So now we
have a very realistic looking three dimensional
model of a coral reef obtained just from a
whole sequence of single camera views.
So I hope that I have convinced you that vision
is a really, really important sensor for all
sorts of animals, for ourselves and also for
robots. So in the rest of the course we are
going to learn something about how we do robot
vision; how do we take information from camera
sensors and process it and generate information
that a robot can take some action on.